what's going on with you Riley we
haven't checked in with you in a while
Riley Mal if you guys have ever met each
other it's my first time meeting him so
the first thing that we said to each
other was um
hey and then he said
well you were gone he said that he took
a lot of pre-workout so he's on pre-work
right pre-workout right now and he could
probably push out 150. I said there's no
way that's true but I didn't know a
thing about not ejaculating ever which I
don't believe
um I'm not saying he's a liar but I just
don't believe it sounds like you're
saying that he's a liar dude one time I
was in one of the things we did early in
my career I was had so many ideas yeah
well like what happened one of my uh
interns at the time he was intern at
barcel wasn't necessarily mine but he
was a young fellow at bar stool
we uh we saw how long he could go
without coming so basically the rules
were no sex no masturbation no no do
anything that mentally with excite you
to that point
you basically just have to live your
life as a Earnest and faithful man
and we'll see how long you go before you
just come
he went 21 days wow in his sleep
so your body comes all the time
is that true Riley
yeah Riley give us an update you and I
haven't checked in in a while either
Riley give us an update and I hate to
just get right into your sexual nature
but when the last we checked you'd never
ejaculate it is that honestly what what
you're saying uh that is true and where
are you at now with it still haven't
have you ever woke up like you woke up
and then you had done it in your dreams
or something like that
uh no no not that I could think of
what do you mean that you could think of
have you ever woken up and it seemed
like somebody had
you know shot a scene of Ghostbusters in
your pants
uh no not really see that's and I've
found it tough sometimes to believe him
but that's what you did out there at the
hunting trip wake up look down here
how's the date in life been for you
what's been going on buddy
uh I've been getting out there more and
more but uh still still single
and he's not gonna burst or nothing
until he's uh wedded in wedlock is part
of his
um religious affiliation is that right
bud that's correct man so do you like I
mean do you that's a and that's part of
like if you're doing Christianity of
probably Muslim like Maine the main
religions I feel like that's part of it
so do you feel like do you does it make
you nervous Riley to be like
to just think about
just that you might do it and get
married and then get nervous that like
it will go just not go how you want it
to or like how do you want it how do you
want it to go the first time yeah I mean
I feel like it's gonna you know you know
I'm gonna be nervous I mean it might not
be as you know what I hope but you know
we'll see it may how much you think is
in there
in him I miss a long time how old are
you 24. yeah that's how long how much do
you think is in there can you feel it at
least one of those like medium ice cream
cups
uh no I don't feel it
yeah okay never mind I'm not gonna say
we don't know each other but kicking
that he's very open about it and we've
discussed it over the years is that he's
waiting for God do you ever just pray
that God touches you in your sleep or
anything like that I don't
do you feel like you do you feel like
you are carrying the extra like do you
feel like your body has stopped your
body is like tuned into what you're
doing and it's like all right let's just
shut down the production of this stuff
for now until we got a wife or you feel
like it's still making it and if so
where do you think your body's holding
it like if you ran out of room and your
testicles or wherever it is where do you
think your your reservoirs are
um no I just you know I just don't think
about it I don't really have any urges
it never came across in my mind
but you in your mind what are you
talking about like surely you think
about women and stuff yeah oh yeah all
the time okay so but then how do you
prevent it from getting to that sexual
space where you're thinking about
pleasuring yourself or rubbing your body
on the carpet until you ejaculate uh it
it just never gets to that point
do you think it's because like you have
good self-control or do you think that
you're just blessed with like a
unproverted disposition so you're just
you just got kind of lucked out
basically yeah I think it's a mixture of
both
that's the part I have trouble believing
sometimes and I don't mean I'm not
calling you out about it but do you feel
like dormant
do you feel like your wiener is dormant
yeah pretty much
that's funny that's [__] crazy
I mean but how are you going to get I
mean how are you going to take that into
a married marriage
ah I I don't know it'll probably just
you know happen when it happens do you
worry that when it does happen it'll be
too much like you just held so much of
it so over the years that it would just
be when it does come out it would be so
much yeah like you're gonna have to call
the manager or whatever
oh probably but I mean that might be a
good thing oh geez dude how many so how
many kids do you think you're carrying
in your body right now oh geez maybe six
times
you're like a dang semen mule
well that's crazy bud what else do you
have any interesting dates recently
Raleigh ah kinda I I have a friend
that's been uh getting me out there more
meeting other girls at you know random
places
and if you had to describe these girls
like what type of women like what
ethnicity or something give me one word
to describe them uh mostly white uh very
cute blonde brunette doesn't matter
um
yeah
okay do you worry about meeting someone
and like you meet the woman that you
really the kind of woman of your dreams
and then
you think it's the one but then at kind
of the last minute she pulls out like
hey I want to see if I want to see if
this this volcano goes off you know I
just want to test it for if it works
because maybe she doesn't wanna
give me you know go into a lifelong
commitment just to make sure that the
yeah say you meet some broad and she
wants to come you up a little before you
guys get hitched what what do you do
what will you say
man I would I would probably uh can you
do that or you can't
I don't know I never really thought
about that
well what do you mean it's like dude
what are your rules like can you do it
or not
you know like that's what I'm saying
buddy I just you know you know what I'm
asking him yeah I think the rule
probably is just no can't do it damn
man well
it's amazing I can't I don't know
anything that hasn't ejaculated in 24
years
except for him
well he has
he has never P.S
you think he's lying yeah well because
it'd be harder to say that if he was in
this room but since he's in the Next
Room I can tell you he's lying that's
true I don't say it to his face but he's
lying and Riley I don't mean that like
that you've done it to yourself or
anything like that but I do think it is
it's science yeah that your body will do
it and that's what that was our
experience uh our experiment at Barstow
was will his name's Robbie who said when
will Robbie's Body do it itself yeah
when will it release itself if Robbie's
not gonna do it when we'll release
itself and it's 21 days oh wow so I
think it's around now I think I think
you can carry carry it for about a month
before it does it in your sleep yeah
that's what Kevin Gates says he does it
all time to sleep really because he's
he's a semen retender oh yeah he's got
his edging or whatever yeah so he said
all the time he's just waking up just
sticky sticky pants
right also I just I don't I don't think
like you're lying I shouldn't have said
you're lying I just don't think maybe
you were sleeping when it happened is
what I'm trying to say no if you were
asleep if you were sleeping you would
know
yeah well you know maybe not well
anything else you need to talk about
what's on your mind
um
do I I'm sorry about what we said
earlier I'm feeling bad about it I'm not
someone needs to figure out we've long
wondered how much what is the reality of
it and people say it a lot is Riley
really
how real could this be that this man
refuses to ejaculate in a very
ejaculatory world
yeah I know it's it's 100 real
you feel like your joints work better
and stuff like that like
uh I just wonder where is it going
because it's going somewhere because
like you're a human body it's all
backing up in you like your whole body
is full of the same how how much food
can you eat before you're full
ah a lot but do you fall and like cut
your leg and it feels so good like
what's coming out of you that's what I
wonder when you bleed like is it white
uh no it's red damn sheesh do you
honestly and there's a real question do
you think something is wrong with you or
not wrong but off with you
uh there might be do you feel like you
might have some type of a sexual autism
or something like that uh
possibly yeah are you being serious or
not no I mean yeah I have no idea it
could be a thing
have you looked into that I mean do you
get it turned on by women yeah how do
you know when you're turned on oh I I
just feel it and what does it feel like
you get erection yeah yeah okay and then
what do you do that's the thing it's
like somebody hand you a Nintendo switch
you never turn it on
no I mean it I mean I just don't do
anything about it do you look at I mean
you have to look at it probably what do
you no
no I just leave it alone do you feel
like it's like mad at you or do you feel
like it's feeling like it's being poorly
treated
like it's like it's kind of my like it's
trying to it's trying to go in the game
and you're like Jameis Winston and
you're like no dude we're sticking with
Andy Dalton
yeah I mean pretty much
I feel like he's not giving us much
information do you I mean it's a
sensitive thing to talk about I
understand why he would not want to give
us information particularly me since I
don't know him but it is interesting
because it sounds like it's he's lying
yeah and I'm sorry Riley am I making you
uncomfortable no no not at all okay
would you tell Caleb the truth yeah yeah
that that was 100 the truth will you
tell me the truth when after Theo leaves
I will okay will it be the same truth
you've already told him yep one thing we
don't realize is all little things have
a play in where we are whether we want
to admit it or not right because they
they affect how you also then want to do
things right it may have said him you
know I don't want it you know I don't I
want to do my own thing more I don't you
know I like some of this but I don't
like a lot of it if I would have never
done that experiment on Robbie Fox with
the coming I would I would not think
he's lying right but since I did that
experiment in my life
a no for fact that he's coming at night
time
or even worse or more more liarish
during the day
right now they don't even know what he's
doing right now dude well he's all
Riley's kind of a smaller and stature
guy how tall are you Riley
I am 5'4 and so how much C I mean he's
like has fulla
you know yeah you got a lot in you man
oh God
it'd be beautiful I just
I think you men a lot of older gay men
would pay to watch him come the first
time I would pay to know how much it was
just to know someone just give me text
me the number of inches or they filled
up in like a water bottle
how much you think you got in your Riley
uh probably a lot oh damn gross dude
now we could do this we could have a
thing even for charity where we get
people to bit like guess a number
like how much little hectounces or heck
you know little mint you know kilo
ounces or whatever it is and whoever
gets the closest but you can't do it for
your own uh religious purposes you can't
that's why you're not masturbating is
that right Riley correct okay if someone
did it to you would you still feel good
about it in terms of like what you're
doing
like you would feel would you feel like
you committed a bad a bad thing if
if Theo this is a crazy question I'm not
enough if Theo tied you up back there
and then had one of his listeners come
in and make you do it
or do you think you have the willpower
where even if that happened to you you
would be able to hold it inside
um I don't know I think I might be able
to hold it
first of all that's a crime I think
isn't it what about this bad question
somebody ties you up a couple Vietnamese
dudes come in here and just start
kicking you in a [__] dick you think
you're gonna [__] ejaculate
eventually
uh I don't know probably not oh come on
dude you got no respect for yourself
this is a this is a question is all this
time itself sorry about this man yeah
we're probably yeah this is insane the
question is oldest time itself
it's the question usually is
would you kill one person to save a
million people
you have to murder one person but you
know that it saves a million people
you'll never see but if you don't murder
that person that's in the room with you
those a million people although you
might not see them
they're going to pass away
would you
fill up a water bottle to save those
million people
I would probably not you would let them
die
I mean I don't wanna I don't want to
kill a man it'll be a million of them
and children and women
well that's not my problem I'm not
killing them that's a good point yeah
he's just not masturbating that's his
rules damn he stands by his rules my bad
that's good so Riley are you in a hurry
to get married do you feel like so you
can be more sexually active
no I'm just I'm just chilling I'm uh
just working on me and you know what I'm
what I'm doing in life but how do you
not get so distracted by women all the
time
I mean I mean I I don't get distracted
but I mean you know I see them when I'm
out on tour
um and you know I talk to them and stuff
but I'm not really like looking for
anything yeah dude that you save so much
time oh yeah you must have tons of time
I'd like to save something like that's
that's awesome yeah you could you could
take an online class you could do
anything you want the only the only
thing that's actually suspect this whole
situation that you're not a billionaire
yeah like that's the only reason I'm
thinking you're lying is because you're
not a billionaire because if you had
that much time yeah at your disposal oh
you take women out of the equation it's
like a guy who just doesn't have to
sleep yeah 24 7 active dude honestly I
just have the piece of bed I don't think
I can think of anything else that's fine
like feeling like I can feel how he
feels yeah all the time
Riley we appreciate and respect whatever
Journey that you're on
and
are you gonna be okay no matter what
yeah I think so
okay are you okay if other people are
sexually active if you have judgment
against those people
uh no no they just they can live their
lives as they please Amen brother
I mean it's crazy to be out there and be
like and to be doing it you know I'm
very envious probably do you think I
mean obviously feel or you know some
people think there's people out there
that think that's fun to hang around
horny guys
do you think that
uh yeah
yeah do you find it more exciting to be
around horny guys would you rather hang
out with a horny guy or a guy who's kind
of
maybe just thinking about something else
probably a horny guy yeah
it's more fun
why
I just feel like they're they would be
more fun than just the guy that's well
like me no no Riley I mean that that's
that's not yeah buddy you're doing good
man
that's a myth also I think that I'm I'm
gonna choose to believe what you're
saying
not that it probably means anything to
you all right but I think that I
I personally feel like we've put you
kind of through the litmus test of every
question you could think of
and all of your answers the all your
answers hold up kind of like if you yeah
none of your answers contradict one
another
which I think is a good good sign
yeah I know I I appreciate it Caleb for
sure yeah and I think in the gay
community it's called a Snick uh
cinnamon cookie or something if
somebody's never ejaculated
do you fear that you could be involved
in the gay community Riley
definitely not okay
and not fear but is it you know have you
thought are you scared for your life
yeah now you telling the truth you know
you pee sometimes in the car and then
you you're like I'm a penis water bottle
and then it you feel it all the way like
oh I gotta cut the stream off or
somebody it's gonna come out the top
yeah like I wonder if it would be the
same thing
he's just got to Kink the hose and get
another water bottle almost like when
they're taking blood to do that thing
and then grab the next one
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one